however good azim rafiq was and he was
good
rafique
his biggest victory has been finding the
courage to call out racism
sharing what he calls
cricket's open secret felt isolated
humiliated at times
um
constant use of the word [ __ ] i mean
2017 pre-season tour we were in a in a
place and gary balance walks over
and goes why are you talking to him you
know he's a [ __ ] um or
he's not a shake he's got no oil
and this happened in front of teammates
it happened in front of coaching staff
for him it was a culture that started
aged 15.
my first intern
of drinking i actually got pinned down
at my local cricket club
and red wine got poured down my throat
how old were you 15 15 you're a muslim
15
15 year old
i got
literally
down my throat
his former teammate gary balance has
already admitted using the p-word
towards rafiq
balance was also accused of being one of
those who would use the name kevin for
any non-white player at yorkshire
kevin was something gary used uh to
describe everyone of color in a very
derogative manner whether that be
publicly
whether that be within the dress room
whether that be opposition this is
an open secret within the england
dressing room
the culture at headingley was one where
racism was normal according to rafiq and
that's why his teammate and england test
captain joe root said last week that he
never saw it
to be clear
ruth is a good man
he's never
engaged in racist language he was
involved in a lot of them socializing
nights out where i'd been called the
[ __ ]
but again
it just shows and he might not remember
it but it just shows how normal it was
in that environment in that institution
that
even a good man like him
doesn't see it for what it is so then
why did he stay in that culture for so
long
when i lost my son i went you know what
hold on a minute
i've seen other players who
have family tragedies and get support
beyond measure and i've just carried my
son from the hospital
to the graveyard and
how i'm getting treated here is not
right and
to me it became very clear that even
myself i'd been looking the other way
and there's a real problem here not just
yorkshire throughout the country for a
person of color to actually
start accepting that you're being
treated differently because of your race
religion is actually quite a tough thing
to take because then after that
you're always like why you just want
answers but you never get answers
of those who have resigned at headingley
in the last few weeks roger hutton is
the only one who faced the questions the
former chairman was asked if yorkshire
county cricket club is or was
institutionally racist
there's been a
substantial amount of thoughtlessness
and ignorance
a reluctance to apologize
a a a reluctance to see a zine was the
victim
and a reluctance to put into place the
uh um the recommendations
which i think are really important in
this process that sounds to me like
you're edging towards the word yes you
were a chair for 18 months and
you've resigned i fear that it falls
within that definition right
this was hiding in plain sight in a
number of cricket clubs around the
country and even if white players and
coaches weren't making the comments
themselves they weren't challenging them
either and this now expands beyond
yorkshire middlesex here at lords have
said that they would like a former
player who azeem rafique has said was
racially abused during his time here to
come forward and speak to them in
confidence
the england and wales cricket board did
acknowledge that they still have work to
do
and this is why
i don't want my son to go anywhere near
cricket
um so
but i think this is where it's the ecb
and the counties
to
show that they can actually use this as
an opportunity for
the change
this is how this moment will be measured
has what this man has said enough to
drive out a culture that has festered in
cricket for generations
tom parmenter sky news